the rotate of Sarma da and Idlib
province in the last two months more
people have fled the fighting here than
at any other time in this area conflict
many are braving the harsh winter
conditions simply to get out it's really
sad to see people here enduring snow and
cold and most of them are children what
are we gonna do we've got nothing left
we're sleeping under olive trees it's a
terrible sight this road is completely
cut off because it's packed full of cars
and people have no idea where they're
going this is what they are leaving
behind violence has flared and it lived
in recent weeks and strained ties
between two of the main international
players in the region Russia and Turkey
Ankara has sent more troops to the area
and has warned it will strike Syrian
regime forces if its soldiers come under
renewed attack anyone targeting Turkey
should know that they will pay the price
for this not only at the site of the
attack but everywhere hundreds of
thousands of people have left in recent
weeks but not everyone can get out those
still stuck in Eid Lib faced an anxious
wait and a worsening humanitarian crisis
and for more on the situation in Syria
I'm joined by Abdel koffie al
hamdulillah teacher in Daraa Tessa a
village on the western countryside of
Aleppo welcome mr. Hondo tell us what is
a situation like for you right now for
you and your family hello how are you
in fact today the situation is getting
worse because the civil regime is
getting closer hello can you hear me yes
I can hear you please do go on yeah
great okay
in fact this regime is getting so close
these day in fact yesterday and today in
fact yesterday we couldn't sleep very
well my little daughter
in fact because of the poems came to me
and told me I want to sleep beside you
because I'm Fred because just imagine
that yesterday my friends who are in the
closer villages they ran away on food
because no cars in fact can dare to go
to these areas in fact now these more
than two millions of people in Italy at
the Western countryside of Aleppo left
their homes and the situation and the
fact they are going to know where these
people are just yes they want to flee
that you want to go that you want to run
away from the bombing but they don't
know where to go and they know that the
regime is gonna be following them again
and they might die yes just yesterday I
died the seven-month son in fact died
because of cold because the situation
the humanitarian situation for those
people who flee who's came from their
houses are in very terrible situation
they are in tents or even sometimes
without tents is either in their cars or
under the trees in this cold weather
it's about six below zero and
nevertheless it's two hell's the hell of
cold and the hell of war planes and
rockets which are upon their heads so
very difficult situation for you mr. al
hamdu a very very difficult situation
from what you're saying what are your
plans are you also planning to leave the
area and go out of Aleppo in fact look
this is the question that my wife is
asking to me all the time I will Cathy
what should we do where should we go the
most difficult question that we fathers
or the breadwinners that we don't know
what we don't know where to go we don't
know what to do yes in fact I prepared
all my things all my important things
just because any time any movement i'ma
I might leave my home with my kids but
where this is the biggest question this
is the most difficult question for us
and just when I see when I look at my
children's eye
and I don't know what to do for them
it's a very difficult situation for me
as a father and for my family really now
yes I'm planning to leave I prepared
everything but I went away to the last
moment because I can't you know stand
living in the wild in the cold because I
might see my kids dying in front of my
eyes so really this is a very difficult
question for me what should you do so
what about what is the situation like in
the village is there enough food and
water and essential supplies for people
who are trapped there right now with the
Syrian troops advancing and as well as
the incredible courage that you talked
about yeah in fact yes my village
because it's a little bit in the close
to the borders nevertheless it's now
close to the pumping because yeah the
Syrian regime now is getting closer to
the borders of Turkey yes there's a food
and and drinks but believe me this is
now the last thing that people think of
they don't think of cool they don't
think of drinks because I in the morning
I went to the market to buy many things
for my wife and I didn't buy I didn't
see anyone buying anything just I'm
alone in the market the streets are just
empty but of the long lines of people
who are fleeing from their homes because
my village it's a little bit like a
corridor for people who tries to move to
North Aleppo so yeah this is the to
material situation here but of course
according to those people who left
everything behind and already they have
nothing in fact they can they can't do
nothing for themselves they can't feed
their kids or they can't you know at
least to have the essential things abdel
coffee
al-hamdu a teacher in italy thank you
very much for sharing your thoughts with
us and we do wish you and your family
all the very best hope you stay safe and
you're able to get out of harm's way